[Music]
hey what's up on today's show we're
going to talk about loving somebody
who's got depression
we've got a couple on and they're going
to talk about their dynamic in their
home
we're going to talk to a young woman who
gave her daughter up for adoption three
years ago and she's struggling with that
phone call every week
we're going to talk to an awesome woman
who is in retirement
has plenty of money and wants to know
after a lifetime of service to her kids
and to her family into her business
is it okay just to bike across america
and have fun in adventures
we're going to talk about tech
boundaries with their kids stay tuned
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john dalone show
the show for you about you by you
you talk about relationships relational
iq your mental health
parenting falling in love falling out of
love
we talk about being on an elevator
crowded everybody's all masked up and
then it door opens
and then instead of people being humans
and waiting their turn for people to get
off the elevator they all just start
piling in like weird fish swimming the
wrong way down the stream
listen here's the rules when the doors
open the people on the elevator
get off first and then the people
outside get in everybody listen
we all took the elevator we were all too
lazy to take the stairs
or we couldn't take the stairs whatever
works
we're all gonna get there a little bit
sooner because we took the metal box
going up and down
let's just wait for people to get off
the elevator and then you get on now
we're on the same page so if you're
looking for honesty in a world where
truth
doesn't exist anymore if you're looking
for a stranger's opinion on what to do
next i'm here
give me a call at six nine 1-844-693
three two nine one that's one eight four
four
six nine three thirty two ninety one
email me at ask john ramsey solutions
dot com
ask john ramsey solutions dot com we're
getting emails from all over the world
it's awesome and hey here's a quick note
a quick plug
i'm getting so many wonderful calls so
many wonderful emails
people are sending their opinions on
things i wish i'd answered it this way
or not that way i love those keep
see keep sending them i'm learning still
i'm getting good information
i've got a team of counselors and mental
health professionals and medical
professionals across the country that i
check in with
i ask them to listen to some calls we
talk about things so
i'm continuing to learn here too um
one thing that's i hear all the time is
i love your show
so much i love your show so much
and i always am crying by the time it's
over and i love that these calls are
resonating the people are calling and
they're being
honest and they're being truthful and
their authenticity is
ringing through the phone like it's
making its way through our headphones
through our podcast and through the
youtube right but i also want to make
sure i'm putting some positivity out in
the world i'm putting some joy out into
the world and so i want to
start a segment on this show that just
acknowledges one
excellent person one person who's being
an outstanding husband an outstanding
wife an outstanding kid
an outstanding dad who used to be a
crappy father and he's turned it around
or somebody who was not a great mom
growing up she had a lot of struggles
and now she's the best grandma
ever so if you've got somebody in your
life that you'd like to shout out
an awesome neighbor who loves your kids
well a
great wife a great husband a wonderful
boyfriend
send it in email me tell me what's going
on
how awesome they are and we're going to
put it on the show i may even call you
and have you
give them a shout out on the show too i
just want to create a segment that's
just like
like like way to go once a week or
something like that something positive
that we can
end the show with i think that'll be
excellent so thank you so much for the
calls for the reviews for the shows and
we've got
hundreds of thousands of downloads in
just a few weeks it's just blowing my
mind here
um but thank you so so much so let's go
straight to the phones
we're doing something a little bit
different today we're gonna talk to a
couple
we're gonna talk to carolyn and matt in
wisconsin
and i'm looking forward to hearing what
they've got going on in their world
good morning carolina matt how can i
help hi dr john
good morning it's good to talk to you
good folks how's wisconsin
well it's getting cold already huh
yeah but it's beautiful this time of
year lots of fall colors so
i love it i love it so how can i help
this morning
so i guess i i will start um
my so my husband is going through a
pretty serious depressive
episode something i've never experienced
in my life before
and ultimately my question is um what
can i do to help him because i'm just
at a loss and i guess i'll let
matt kind of explain where he's coming
from
yeah so um so dr john probably about
three months ago
and i i i mean this entire year has just
been kind of mentally taxing but about
three months ago i just kind of
went to a pretty dark place and um it's
been
pretty difficult and i sought out
counseling rather quickly um
and i ended up working with my doctor as
well
um to to see about medication so um like
i'm trying to be proactive with this
thing but
um it's it's really been pretty tough
so when you say dark place and pretty
tough those are general words
um what do you mean by that might be
specific well
yeah so um i think the thing that's
been the most alarming is that
emotionally
i've just felt checked out it's been
really difficult for me to be present
in in situations i mean we have a
one-year-old daughter
and she just had her birthday a couple
weeks
ago and and i found it really difficult
to be present during that
um and so um
i just i felt really i've been feeling
really overwhelmed lately
just by work and and our living
arrangements and and just
you know the fact that being 25
and and both of us being 25 and having
student debt and and
needing to get out of that and just life
just
ramped up and it feels like uh you know
obviously it's it's never going to slow
down but i just i've been feeling pretty
overwhelmed lately
so before i dig in a little bit deeper
matt i want to tell you
brother um i want to high five you
i want to give you a hug from nashville
um
it took a lot of courage for you to go
see somebody to get on the right meds
and to say something pretty quick um
that you are struggling and so
i want to give you a shout out that's
that's impressive and that's a good deal
and that also for whatever it's worth
is a sign of good things to come one of
the most challenging things when folks
get down into that dark hole and they
feel like they're underwater is they
don't reach out
and you did and i want you to know that
bodes well for you getting well in the
future okay
um so talk to me about how long this has
lasted is this something you dealt with
as a kid is this kind of out of nowhere
you have it you have a
new baby in the house and all of a
sudden you just feel like you're getting
dragged under the carpet what's
what's the trajectory on this how long
has it been going on
well um i think uh
i didn't really i didn't really
experience anything like this when i was
a kid
and and i think that's the thing that's
been most alarming to me is just
not ever you know what i mean honestly
i've never felt this way but it's almost
like you don't feel anything
you know that's almost what it feels
like you just you know you're kind of
void of feeling but um
this year i mean everything with work
everything just kind of hit the fan and
and uh i i probably
didn't really see the warning signs that
things weren't going well you know like
just becoming quick tempered and
not really engaging in the workplace
just because you know
we have so many problems that we just
don't have solutions for
right now and i think things got really
bad
though uh just around the end of july so
it's been
just shy of three months that things got
really quite bad and honestly if i if
i'm honest with myself and through
counseling
um getting to see what kind of led up to
this point
that there were definite warning signs
that i probably just didn't make note of
that probably you know should have i
don't know should have
should have been a little more obvious
to me but so uh
this ramps up so carolyn tell me how
this experience has been for you
be specific what have you been
experiencing so
it's it's been kind of tough because um
i i feel like um
like i'm the only um i'm sorry
oh you're good like like i'm i have to
be the adult
um i have to um
make sure that
our daughter is getting taken care of
and we're um
hitting our goals financially and just
all those all those things that
we were always a team for um
he because he struggled to be present
it's it's hard for me to talk to him i
feel like
anything that i i say to him i should be
saying something that's going to be
helping him
um and um because i'm struggling to talk
to him he feels like he's
a million miles away from me and
obviously i don't want him to feel that
way i want him to know that i'm right
here
i want to help him i want to be here um
and we're going to get through it
together
but it's it's difficult for me to
i i don't know i just i feel like it's
wrong with me to want to
continue to work on these other life
things
when he's going through this so i want
to give you a shout out to for being
brave and saying what's actually
in your heart because the the demon of
being in love with somebody who's
struggling with something
is that you feel guilty for having your
own feelings and for being
frustrated and for feeling like you've
got to be as you said perfectly the only
adult in the house right
and it's exhausting and it's a beating
and at the same time you can't say that
out loud right because you feel like
you're gonna
put another foot on somebody's head
who's already drowning right
exactly yeah and so i want to high five
you for being a supportive spouse who
loves her husband
and who is trying to raise a little baby
and who is brave enough and bold enough
to have her own feelings and be able to
express them that's a big deal
okay and i want you to minimize that
cool
so hey matt do you love your wife
or yeah more than anything do you trust
her
yep okay um
when you've worked with your doctor what
did they do they give you some diagnosis
do they tell you you've got something
yeah um my my doctor was pretty
convinced just
based off of talking with me for a few
minutes that um
that she thinks i was going through a
rather severe
bout of depression and might have been
compounded by some anxiety
brought on by various situations that
happened this year
okay um so
and then my counselor feels the same way
um and actually recommended that i reach
out to my
my doctor and actually was working with
my doctor hand in hand which was really
nice
that's awesome have you had suicidal
thoughts have you thought about hurting
yourself
no i i haven't okay okay so
i i want to give you all a couple of
things to think through as a couple
and i'm gonna matt i'm gonna talk more
to carolyn
okay but i want to give you some
thoughts too
and you're working with two
professionals and so i want to i don't
want to get in the weeds i don't want to
get in the way of the work they're doing
together with you okay
but i'll give you some 30 000 foot stuff
um
here's a couple of she's and he's right
so
it's important for carolyn it's
important for you
when he sits down and has the courage to
tell you here's what i'm feeling right
now
it's important not to minimize that with
yeah but we have this and yeah but we
have vats and i know that's hard right
but on the other hand matt it's
important that when you are having
up moments when you are not in the
toilet when you are not under water
that you're able to talk to her with
words okay
you hear that matt yep and
she probably experiences you under a
blanket or experiences you staying in
bed yet again and
what happens is there becomes this
little sliver becomes a break
and it's that gulf gets wider and wider
and then you touch less
and then you kiss less and then you
talk less and suddenly you are a
thousand miles apart right
even though you're sleeping in the same
bed and so it's important that you use
words and at the same time um you've got
to trust her
that if she tells you something that
she's not lying to you right
right the most important thing i want
people with depression to hear
is that your feelings are real and that
your feelings lie to you
and one of the greatest gifts somebody
who's struggling from depression is
somebody that is trustworthy that's with
them walking alongside them that can say
i get that you feel like this is always
going to be this way
but it's not i get that you feel like
your business is all your fault
and that you're a terrible dad and
you're not
and that's when somebody who's
struggling with depression can just
gently gently lean against
that truth and know my my
the nerd word is cognitive distortions
my brain's lying to me right now
i am a person of value i am worthy of my
daughter's love and my wife's love
and she's doing what she can right and
so um
the challenge for you carolyn is to
continue to be honest
and to continue to speak your truth and
to be honest
with him directly but not in a way that
crushes him right and that's like you're
gonna have to be walking a tightrope and
by the way you're carrying a
one-year-old around right
right so here's what i'd recommend i'd
recommend
you set up some specific times when you
want to have
conversations about you and you're
allowed to do that and matt i'm going to
ask you as part of your little wins
to know that she needs you too right
because you
have value in this relationship you're
important this relationship and i want
you to be a part of her being well too
right
right and one of the suckers one of the
demons of depression is that you got no
value so here is
your wife needs you your daughter needs
you and so when she says hey
let's have a let's have go for a walk
today let's have a talk today
i want you to feel empowered and feel
like sweet i've got value here
i may be sucking at work i may not want
to get out of bed but i'm going to trust
her and i'm going to lean up against
this and we're going to have this
conversation
um and i want you carolyn to focus on a
series of little wins
my guess is you know before he does when
he's headed down a path is that fair
yes okay so you could probably tell he
eats a little bit less he's starting to
be a little bit quieter a little bit
sharper he's going to bed a little bit
earlier right you can usually tell
good a good partner can tell ah
man here we go again my wife will tell
me
you've spent a lot of time x y and z the
last two days
and that's a good signal to me that i'm
headed down a road i didn't even know i
was on right
and matt i want you to trust her that
when she sets up and carolyn i want you
to go take some time
and think about five or ten behaviors
that you see in matt
that are the signal behaviors he's
headed down a road
he's starting to eat a lot more doritos
and twinkies this week
or whatever the thing is um and then
matt i want you to be encouraged this
way
i want you to trust her and not get
heartbroken and frustrated and i know
that's super easy right that's the demon
of depression you can't just not do it
but i want you to it's just a matter of
a degree
to lean up against her and trust her and
her and she's being honest with you is
that fair
okay yep and then i want you to and
there's gonna be days when you look at
her and say i just can't go for that
walk
and don't beat yourself up don't don't
grind yourself down she'll say great i'm
going for that walk
and i want you to go carolyn and i want
you to take the baby
and matt if you can if you can make
yourself go go
and if you can't make yourself go lean
up against her and see if you can go
again
okay this is about little tiny wins
and what's going to slowly start
happening you're going to work with your
counselor still you're going to continue
to work with your doctor
and most importantly you're going to
begin to reconnect with your wife
and i want you to hold that baby girl
and when you have feelings of i
suck as a dad i want you to challenge
those feelings because here's the deal
you don't
and when you have those feelings of i'm
being a crummy husband i'm not good
enough to be a husband and a dad
i want you to know your feelings are
lying to you and you have a woman that
you trust and she's telling you
that's not true
that's not true carolyn i want you to
work with him i want you to work with
yourself
on putting your thoughts out on paper
and challenging them right demanding
evidence from those thoughts those dark
dark circular just thoughts right
and continue and continue and here's the
deal carolyn do you have somebody that
you can talk to
right now um
probably i haven't really thought about
it so here's the suckiest part about
loving somebody who's hurting
you are the only person that can take
care of you and you can't fix them
and so the best thing you can do for you
right now is to be well the best thing
you can do for your one-year-old little
baby right now is you be well
and we've talked a lot we've talked for
15 minutes about you helping him
but the reality is you've got to help
yourself here and so you need to make
sure
you're exercising you've got to put on
your oxygen mask first you got to
exercise
you got to find friends or a counselor
to talk to
you've got to spend quality one-on-one
eye contact joyful laughing time with
that little baby
and that's gonna lift up the entire
house like a hot air balloon right
okay you can't
listen to me you cannot feel guilty for
taking care of yourself in this season
okay
okay do you promise i promise
say i promise i promise
all right yeah little girl needs you you
need you
and matt needs you loving somebody with
depression is hard but it's also
gritty gnarly work that is good
and it is right and it's holy and it's
hard and it's
tearful if anybody listening to this
here's a couple of things depression
lies to you
it tells you this is your fault this is
always going to be this way
and eventually it rolls into in your
burden on those around you and it's a
lie it's not true
and if you love somebody with depression
you can't see their broken leg
you can't see their their bloody knees
and so it begins to feel like is this
real because i'm carrying all this crap
and i want to tell you folks who
are struggling in the throes of
depression it's very real
and you all know me enough i'm not a
huge fan of just
racing to medication if you're
struggling with depression
medication is often a great support
system
especially for helping you climb out of
that pit and begin to do the hard work
of counseling and hard work of
reconnecting
depression is rarely from a single thing
it just comes on you
and it's often seasonal and so i'm
encouraged by the fact that he didn't
experience this as a young child i'm
encouraged by the fact that
they've got a one-year-old baby in the
house and this kind of came on him in a
season
and that tells me that it could be
seasonal especially if he continues to
be brave and do the hard work
um matt you are blessed to be on measure
to have carolyn and carolyn you are a
saint and a wonderful wife
high five to you ah what a blessing all
right let's go to
um let's go where we're gonna go to next
let's go to lexington kentucky
and talk to eva how are we doing this
morning eva
good morning dr darani thank you for
taking my call
thank you for calling it's my pleasure
how can i help this morning
well i'm 61 years old
and i decided to retire next year
okay and financially will be fine
that's not the problem i'm kind of
struggling with the transition though
why are you struggling uh well you know
all our life we were working full-time
we raised three children so
our life was pretty busy and i was
always busy and i just
worried that one day i will wake up and
you know think how i'm going to justify
my existence
so you've got all the money to retire
you've raised your kids and now you're
wondering what was it all for
no no no not in that sense it's just
that
i don't want to spend the rest of my
life
you know just watching netflix and
seeing the the birds fly by
and i i have something that i want to do
you know but there are fun things so eva
what are they what do you want to do
well i'm thinking about riding bicycle
across america
you do it not that hard do it
hey so what's stopping you from going to
buy an awesome bike
besides that it's winter um going to get
a bike and riding it across the country
what's stopping you well no i'm going to
do it
yes good but
you know it's all everything that i want
to do
like travel and spend time with families
it's all fun right and i feel like i'm
you know i worry that i will feel like i
don't contribute anything that's my
problem
tell me about how many kids you have
three
are they wonderful they're good kids yes
did you do a good job
i hope so now evan did you do a good job
i guess they are not in chairs
do you have any grandkids not yet
but they're coming i hope so you know
the kids are just coming out of college
so ah okay
so here's the thing eva you deserve to
have fun
and joy is and fun and adventure
is a cornerstone part of
a good whole life and
i've never heard i've sat with a lot of
people who have passed away
i've sat with a lot of people whose
loved ones have passed away
i've never ever heard somebody say
i wish i had less fewer adventures i
wish i'd had less fun and i wish i had
just worked more
and produced more i've never heard that
sentence
that's very true yeah and one of the
things folks do when they
they get in a season of mission a season
of focus or productivity
when you got three kids you've got a
business you've been successful so that
you can grab
i mean you can uh graduate literally
graduate you can retire at 61
is you get driven and you produce and
you
focus and you do and you accomplish and
you achieve
and man if you don't stop along the way
to ride the bike across america man
that's what you're gonna regret
so i want you ever to have as much
permission as you want
to go have fun go have adventures i know
you
you're gonna have that first grandkid
and you're gonna be that crazy grandma
who wants to move in next door you're
gonna be
all in their business and it's gonna be
so wonderful and good
maybe not for them hey it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
right but you were um you're gonna find
mission
right now you want permission to just
let your hair down a little bit and you
fully fully got it
fully got it okay i guess i needed to
hear that
do you have some um some young man that
you spend time with
young man meaning your husband
oh yeah i have my husband yes but he's a
homebody so he's
perfectly content sitting at home and
he's doing some
stuff is he still handsome oh yeah yeah
oh good hey get a two-seater bike and
strap him to the back and you all ride
across america it's gonna be incredible
you got it
[Music]
yes i will try all right good eva you're
gonna
go forever ever ever ever and you're
gonna go across america
y'all are gonna laugh and have
adventures because you've earned it
you've put in the hard work the hard
work the hard work
i'm just i'm i'm excited for you i'm
excited for you and you're going to find
purpose you're going to find mission i
already know that stuff's going to
happen
you're going to be an awesome
grandparent but you're not going to get
to the end of your days and
regret not having more joy and you're
not going to get to the end of your days
and whatever
proverbial bike ride across america is
even if you don't end up doing that even
if you just go camping or start quilting
or whatever thing it is you become a
catfisher
woman what i don't know what it is
whatever you're gonna do um
go have adventures and have fun you're
61 you are still young you're still
beautiful
you got a handsome guy in in in tow
i'm excited for you man that's so cool
all right let's go to
jacob we'll go back uh jacob in
actually let's don't go to jacob i want
to go to
a quick little segment here
this is something that's come up quite a
few times with
my friends and family it's come up over
and over in the emails
it's come up on the youtube chats
and then this um
netflix documentary came out and
everyone went abuzz
and so i want to talk about tech
boundaries with your kids
i want to talk about this wackadoo
season that we are in
we are amidst one of the greatest social
experiments
of all time we're almost overnight
and i'm talking about from like 2010 to
2019
we started putting everything up online
we started spending
lots and lots of hours playing video
games we started putting everything on
facebook all of our family photos all of
our friends all the things we love
all the things that we are interested in
and the tech companies started tracking
us and listening to us
and watching us and then watching how we
behaved and how we answered things and
whether we loved things or didn't love
things and liked things and
then all of a sudden 2020 hit and
everyone went home
and what little privacy left but little
human interaction
left between a teacher and a student
between
a college professor and their grad
student
all of that went online
but hard conversations between a boss
and employee
that went online we're doing everything
virtually now
and so we have taken all of our lives
and dumped them
into the internets onto zoom
onto facetime onto all these platforms
into these laptops
we are doing a massive social experiment
we are putting everybody's
words and thoughts and dreams and hopes
in snapshots with
our normal developmental processes we
are putting them in black and white to
be etched in stone forever they're
always going to be there
and we don't know how this wraps up
right
if you haven't watched the social
dilemma watch it it's intense
and it will hopefully make you rethink
some things about the way you engage
with social media the way you engage
with the computers
but i want to talk about screen time
with kids screen time in your homes i
think tech can be
it's got some great uses it's got some
really extraordinary things that help us
see
different pictures of our earth of our
world of relationships etc
but can also be dangerous and handing a
and i don't say dangerous in some
dramatic orwellian
dun dun kind of way what i mean is
kids or kids and we live in a world now
where folks are going back and mining
things that 14 year olds said
that 12 year olds said that 18 year olds
said the 25 year old said
and we have this science that say their
brains aren't developed and we have this
science that says they are not smart
and yet we are holding people
accountable they're putting things in
black and white that they can't take
back
their bullying is happening in a way
used to your neighborhood
bully said something to you and it went
in one ear and you got sad and you got
your heart broken and you got punched in
the stomach or whatever happened
and then it it was gone and you had a
group of friends and over time it heals
or it doesn't
right it lodges itself in you and you
work it you work it out
now you just see it in black and white
and you read it over and over
and over according to some google
analytics pornography searches increase
by
4700 percent when children under the age
of 18 are not in school
instead of asking their buddy what such
and such such and such is
or asking their mom or dad they just
google it
and so kids are being raised some of
these hard questions
what's the meaning of life is god real i
don't know what this particular sex act
is instead of finding somebody to ask
they're just going to the computer and
they're getting to see it in real time
they're going to see a lot of violence
they're going to see a lot of
things that they may never have
experienced some of that's good not the
violence part but sometimes seeing that
other people do christmas differently
than they do
other people sing and dance differently
than they do that's great stuff
but some of it can be negative and so
here's the thing i want parents to stop
for a minute we thought this was going
to be a few weeks to quote unquote
flatten the curve right and here we are
nine months later
um i want you to step back and
parents have a hard conversation with
themselves with each other
if you're a single parent i want you to
get with a friend and i want you all to
talk together about tech boundaries in
your house
and i'm not saying this to be an
alarmist i'm saying this this is what i
do in my own home
and this is a big deal to me for a
hundred different reasons that we can
talk about later
but a couple of things i want to
recommend folks do
number one i want you to lead by example
moms and dads
single moms and single dads married
couples
i want you to lead by example put the
screens away and this is the pot talking
to the kettle here man during the
hurricanes during the
covet kick up during the some of the
election stuff man i'm finding myself
glued to it
even my astros made it back to the
championship series and i found myself
checking in on them
man we got to lead by example that means
we got to put our screens down and start
looking our kids in the eyes
number two if they are at school on zoom
all day
or if they go to school and their school
has a big
chromebook program where they just sit
in front of a computer all day
that goes into their overall screen time
count for the day
so if they're if they are in school by
zoom
then when school's out the screens are
off that is their time for the day
they don't need to then pick up the
phone and then pick up netflix and then
pick up video games that's their time
okay that means we're gonna have to get
soccer balls again that means we're
gonna have to get tennis balls and old
tires and sticks i don't care what it is
that means we're gonna have to go to a
neighborhood park with a mask on or
whatever it is in your community
wherever you are listening to this
but that means the screen time's up
because we're we're slowly
morphing our kids to where they're
spending 10 hours a day on a screen and
we're calling it different because one
school and one's counseling and one's
violin practice my son's doing his
violin via zoom right now
um and then all of a sudden it's now i
get my tv time it's like no man you've
got your screens you've got your screens
number two i want you to have a family
meeting with your kids
and i want you just to be honest with
them and say we were not designed to
stare in front of a screen
12 hours a day 10 hours a day eight
hours a day and so we're gonna
have a cold turkey cut starting that's
kind of funny cold turkey cuts that was
hilarious i didn't mean to do that but
we're gonna start
stopping this we're gonna put a period
at the end of these sentences we're
gonna quit
spending so much time on the screens and
then i want you to write a plan and put
it in a common area
i'll just tell you in my house my kids
get one or two
shows a week sometimes that's a movie
they get
by themselves me and my wife just wanna
have a date night sometimes that is
saturday morning cartoons
and they can watch a couple of whatever
episodes on disney plus or whatever it
is
um but we try to be pretty intentional
what that means is we gotta go play with
them that means
i gotta not just sit there and scroll
mindlessly through the astros game
and whatever election nonsense is going
on i gotta go actually go play with my
kids
and it's frustrating and it's tiring and
i never
ever ever regret it i want you to
not let kids have phones or tablets or
screens in their bedrooms
don't do that people ask me all the time
i know i'm a little bit of a lunatic
when it comes to this stuff
my kids don't have phones they're not
gonna have phones i've drawn that line
i've worked with too many folks behind
closed doors about tech with tech stuff
i've got too many friends who have
worked in the tech industries
it's just a terrible idea if you dig
into it folks in the tech industries
don't let their kids have screens
they don't let their kids have phones in
their bedrooms because they know
and so i want to challenge you all i
know you're going to send me your cards
and letters and
i can't believe it's child abuse you
don't give your kid a phone fine call on
me
i want you to replace screen time and i
say this over and over and over again
replace screen time with human beings
that could be you
that could be play dates that could be
go to the part-time that could be just
go for walk time i don't care what it is
i promise downstream it will help you
too and the last thing is this
i can't tell you how many times over the
years i've heard my kid's addicted to
his phone
my 14 year old is addicted to his ipad
my six year old
is addicted to whatever screen whatever
tv show
bullcrap no 14 year olds addicted to a
screen
that a parent hasn't handed them no
seven year old is addicted to an ipad or
an iphone
that a parent hasn't handed them you are
the boss
moms and dads and for single parents who
are working three jobs trying to figure
it out
this sucks i wish there was another way
to say this nicely this is awful
it sucks it's heavy and it's hard i get
that i so get that you get home
and you just want to lay down it's
exhausting
you get tears in your eyes just thinking
about it it's exhausting
i know but you're the boss
and if we gotta go get coloring books we
gotta go get
legos and blocks or whatever the thing
is i don't give your kid a shovel and
something to dig a hole
i don't care what it is but you're in
charge of the screens
you're in charge of what they're doing
in their off
time i want to give every parent
permission to take those reins back
take them back think of your kids
overall screen time as
a big picture not just school
and then violin and then
entertainment and then weekends and then
and then and then
we can do it and i am optimistic that
this thing rallies around that we all
realize
man after nine months of just
being captivated by screens and video
games and more stuff that we all go
whoa this wasn't life
so i want to go to jacob jacob actually
called in here jacob in wisconsin
jacob wrote in and sent me a real nice
email we did a show a few weeks ago
about a husband who was addicted to
video games and jacob
wrote in and i just said hey i want to
talk to jacob directly so
jacob it's good to hear from you brother
how are you doing this morning
i'm doing fantastic how about yourself
i'm doing good
so you sent me a uh an email
and so tell us about it tell us what you
sent
so i sent an email in uh after i heard
your show
talking about uh the husband who was
addicted to video games
and that really resonated with me in my
life because i
i lived it uh in my college years i
i was addicted to a video game and i
played it
way way more than was healthy so
wanted to uh to share my story
man so what advice would you give
somebody who loves somebody who's
addicted to video games or to a 22 year
old who's listening to this
or a 38 year old who's got two kids and
uses video games just to hide what would
you what would you tell them
so the advice to the uh to someone who
is living with or you know updating
somebody or made to somebody who's
addicted to video games
be willing to stand your ground be
willing to stand firm
and set a boundary around looking back
like i ultimately
was given an ultimatum that it'd be the
my fiance or the video game
and that was the best ultimatum of my
life
and you chose fiance right oh god yeah
okay good deal good deal and
sadly i can look back at that time and
say it was actually a difficult choice
for me
and i it's something that i'm ashamed to
admit but i feel like it's important
for people to hear and know that it
really can get to be that
much of a presence in your life because
it is addicting it can be addicting
what would you tell the 38 year old
who's stuck right now
there's a better way and the people that
you engage with online
they feel like you're friends and when
you're
playing the game they interact with you
like friends
but when push comes to show they're not
going to be at your table
when times get tough they're not going
to be there to help you
when life gets hard
and if you play the game to the point
that i did where i was
i was playing it more than 40 hours a
week
nobody else stays around because you
don't have the time to invest in the
real relationships
what's one one thing you would like one
tactile one thing you would tell
somebody you need to do this right now
what would that be
you've just gotta you've gotta get
something else in your life
uh one of the things i did to help break
it was i
i started bicycling and i just i got out
and i spent
an hour a day just going and doing
something different something that would
help me direct my focus elsewhere
and so like i was just talking about
with parents and these tech boundaries
you were trying to get off of video
games and so you chose another behavior
which was riding bikes outside for an
hour
did that end up healing other parts of
your life too
oh yeah i mean it made a huge difference
for me physically as well i mean i was
you know playing uh playing a game 40
plus hours a week
and sitting in a chair would lead to a
positive
physical health either yeah you weren't
super ripped huh
no definitely not man
well jacob man i want to number one just
thank you for reaching out
i appreciate all the emails and cards
and letters even the positive ones the
negative ones i love them
but more importantly i want you to pat
yourself on the back man i want to thank
you so much for reaching out and
letting me know about your journey
letting me know that you've got a heart
for people who are stuck in this video
game thing and if you don't play video
games like me
it's easy to go what are you talking
about
this is like a controller it's up up
down down left right left right
you're like ba select start right this
isn't like what are you talking about is
addicting
and then i forget that i've got my own
challenges i've got my own addictions
i've got my own drama in my life
and so i want to thank you for having
the courage to just come on the show and
tell everybody there's a better way
if you are in love with somebody who's
addicted to video games stand your
ground
have an ultimatum and if you are playing
video games 30 hours a week 20 hours a
week 40 hours a week
there is a better life there are going
to be real people around real tables
that
provide you real vulnerability and real
joy in real life
and you're worth making those changes so
man jacob i'm really grateful for you
brother
all right let's take one more call let's
go to rachel in austin texas
rachel good morning how can i help
good morning how are you i'm good i'm
good so what's going on
um so about almost three years ago i
placed a little girl up for adoption
um it is an open adoption um
but i guess i'm i'm going through that
i'm kind of processing it now
to where i'm going through that i guess
you would say trauma
um and i don't really know how to get
through it yeah
because she's getting older she's
getting more of a personality and
becoming more of a person to interact
with huh
yeah we still talk like once a week um
but i mean i i just don't know how to
how to have those interactions without
letting her
i guess live her own life with her her
adoptive family
so paint me a picture of what that
struggle's like
um so we'll maybe have a call once a
week
we'll we'll talk about how her day
is how she's doing with school stuff
like that
um and then you know she'll go about her
day but then
whenever that that phone call ends i
kind of have this
i guess this disconnection and then this
kind of emptiness
you know and you know that's okay right
yeah i do i mean i'm real close to the
adoptive parents
um but are they doing a great job oh
they're doing an amazing job
amazing so how young were you when you
got pregnant
21 21 and what sets you on the path
to make the courageous decision to adopt
your baby
out oh i wasn't ready and i knew that
yeah absolutely not ready and this
family they had that i had i placed her
fort with
um they had been trying for over 10
years
so it was absolutely time and i knew
they were perfect
but i guess it's kind of just getting to
that point of i'm just
preparing myself for that question of
you know why didn't you want me
kind of thing yeah one thing i'd
recommend you do that would be a great
great gift to this baby and
not only this baby but this kid and not
only this kid but this young woman
and not only this young woman but this
future mother someday herself
is if you began to honor yourself and
honor her
by writing down your experiences and
keeping
really detailed journal notes for her
because one day you're right she's gonna
come and say hey mom how come
and 10 years from now you're not gonna
have as good an answer as you did
three years ago right but if you've got
a journal
a serial series right of
i miss you and i'm so grateful you're in
the place you're supposed to be
and your parents were incredible and i
wasn't ready
and one day she will recognize the
courageous gangster
awesome mother that you are in that you
knew enough to know that the best thing
for her was to give
her for give her to a great wonderful
family who had the
the scope and the means to raise her and
open adoptions are beautiful and they
are really really hard
because these are uncharted waters right
we're not used to this
but i also want you to honor the fact
that you
know that you did the right thing and
this also sucks
and one thing that we don't do good as a
society is to live in this tension
of it's got to be either awful or really
great
and this is just a middle road right
where it's going to be this bittersweet
joy and excitement and also really hard
and really frustrating
do you have somebody in your life that
you can be open with
i do how do those conversations go
um it's normally with my sister she's
the one who who was there and read
read me the adoption papers that i
signed in the hospital
um and that she she's been through
everything with me
but she she's open with them
she actually talks to the adopted
parents too and
so we have really great communication
yeah they sound wonderful
so what's something that brings you joy
these days
um i mean it's probably talking to her
once a week
really that's probably it so i want you
to spend more time talking to her
on pen and paper or open up a word
document and just start writing
and one of the greatest gifts you will
give her one day is knowing that she's
not alone and she's not crazy
and that she will have a play-by-play of
how much
her birth mother truly loved her she
will have the connective experience
of her adoptive family that raised her
and loved her
and there could be a moment here when
she's 18 19 20 21 when she gets to
just be showered by love that some of us
may never get to experience
she's going to have two moms that love
her more than life itself right
and also it may be come time when you
have to protect yourself
and if you're not healthy for her then
letting her know we're going to talk
every other
week or every other other yeah i think
that i think that's where i'm at because
i don't
i don't really know where that line is
between
i want you to be with your adoptive
family but
i kind of want you to make your own
decision as to whether i'm in your life
or not
right and for a three-year-old that's
not fair because she's three
yeah for a ten-year-old that's not fair
for a 21 year old that's fair
and so if you don't feel like you're in
a place where you can
honor that relationship and i say honor
it it's messy and it's hard but that you
can connect with her and she knows you
and it's
well but if you're doing it just to
fulfill you
that can be really hard on her
and so maybe practice see what it's like
to do every two weeks
see what it's like to do every three
weeks you're playing a marathon
here so if you miss a week you miss a
week right
yeah and i don't want to undermine or
um that undermines the wrong word i
don't want to minimize okay
but i'll just tell you this experience
my wife is an extraordinary
scholar and researcher and she was asked
to come work at a school for a few weeks
in brazil
when my son was i think he was three or
maybe he was four
and so i went with her and i brought him
and
my son and i were in sao paulo outside
of sao paulo brazil
and we had two weeks of just father-son
time and we were in the parks
and we were went to these weird places
where he got to
ride donkeys into the jungle and two
cans were like flying around
and we pulled mangoes and avocados off
of trees i mean it was extraordinary
it was a once in a lifetime trip me and
my son
in the jungle with meeting wonderful
people eating new foods
and he's 10 now and he remembers not one
second of that trip at all
none and so i tell you that to tell you
this
if you are working on your heart in this
deal
if you are working on i want to see if i
can go two weeks
i want to see if i can go a month
between these conversations i need to
begin to let go of the reins because i
feel
my grip is getting tighter and tighter
and that tight tight grip is going to
hurt her
she's going to know you loved her she's
going to be able to read that journal
you're going to be writing
she's going to be loved by her adoptive
family and she's not going to remember
that mom missed a week once
or that mom went from every week to
every month
she's not going to remember that
you will but she won't
yeah do you have any other kids
no i do not okay when you have your next
kid
one day it will be hard then too i think
instead of your sister or in addition to
your sister i think it'd be wise for you
rachel
to get a counselor just to talk through
it
because i think that the separation part
is going to be hard here especially as
you're 24 25
26 you're coming here into your own um
you have full-time employment you meet
somebody
and you get a stable home it's going to
be harder and harder and i think having
somebody that will navigate this not
just as your sister she's great good
person to be vulnerable with
but having someone that can teach you
some skills on how to take care of
yourself your heart and mind in this
thing
i think that would be really awesome so
as we wrap it up i want to thank
everybody for calling
um man good calls
i want to leave us with this song
easily easily the greatest song ever
written
most people don't think of this band
when they think of incredible 80s bands
these weren't just an incredible 80s man
this was the 80s band
it's from their 1989 album the great
radio controversy
the greatest band of all time tesla
and their greatest song of all time it's
just called love song
and it goes so you think that it's over
that your love has finally reached the
end anytime you call night or day
i'll be right there for you when you
need a friend
it's going to take a little time time is
sure to mend your broken heart but don't
you even
worry pretty darling you could say
pretty darling back in the 80s
i know you're going to find love again
love is all around you
love is knocking outside your door
waiting for you is the love made just
for two
keep an open heart and darling you'll
find love again
i know woohoo tesla
love song love it this is the dr john
deloney show